we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail i received about a recent
patriot mail episode by the way that was
the most interesting patriot mail i've
ever seen on this show you should do
that you should pick one in years this
was the best patriot mail of the year
this guy would be a good candidate
either freaking [ __ ]
I at this point in time I cannot believe
anybody would still support the
incompetent illegitimate drum just blows
my frickin mind Oh
the the naivete forty percent nearly of
the country still supports Trump and I
know that that people like you and me
and and you know people that understand
what's going on we are shocked that
there are still people supporting Trump
but you've got to get over that we've
got to get over that and go to the
pragmatics of how we can actually get
people involved in voting in 2017
special elections in 2018 and ultimately
in 2020 because the guy is teetering
between 35 and 40 percent support that
is incredibly disturbing on today's
bonus show we will talk about the
Catalonian independence vote which send
it into total chaos in Spain we will
talk about new regulations on edible
marijuana in Colorado and also we have a
congressman fresh out of prison wanting
to get back into politics yeah I'm
talking about congressman Michael Grimm
those stories and more on the bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show
with david pakman.com slash membership
you can also access the bonus show now
by becoming a $5 a month patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
appreciate everybody support hoping to
have a really solid month here in
october grow our support i'm and have
actually something to announce regarding
new content on the program maybe in a
week or two so all very exciting things
and i will talk to you more on today's
bonus show